du haut de ses 23 ans on pourrait le
prendre pour un gamin que tout amusé
mais ce jour là has l'audience nicolas
s'apprête à risquer sa vie pour en
sauver d'autres on va aller à 6 vers ce
qu'il n'y a pas de bon ou de mauvais
moment pour y aller c'est la guerre mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez il faut bien
aller évacuer les gens
pas tombeau ouvert sur des routes de
campagne qui longe la ligne de front
direction sieverts sq sous le feu nourri
de l'artillerie ruche
là on est en train de récupérer des gens
bons la maison des voisins a été
complètement détruite
et là on entend des bombardements
le calme après la tempête les cinq
nouveaux déplacés sont accueillis dans
cette congrégation qui va les aider à
sortir de la région demain vous pouvez
aller à pokrovski et de pourquoi vous
pourrez aller à lviv je vais passer des
appels maintenant vous pouvez vous
détendre maintenant non là je ne peux
pas me calmer j'en suis incapable
après la nuit dernière on s'est dit
qu'il fallait faire quelque chose dieu
merci les volontaires survenus et la
route était assez dégagé ils ont roulé
très vite mais on était
on a dû partir à toute vitesse on a pris
ce qu'on pouvait ce qu'on avait sous la
main
un peu déboussolés la petite troupe
gagne les chambres à l'étagé
elle pourra rester là une nuit dehors on
peut voir loin les fumées de la guerre
le front n'est qu'à 11 km à portée de
canon